all right Christopher
Christopher where are you from
originally uh I'm from Washington I
spent most of my life in Clallam
which is a district
there's about four of them in Washington
uh originally I'm from Port Angeles
which is literally On the Border uh to
Canada Canada is only three miles across
what was your childhood like
uh I moved a lot
um unfortunately I also got to know it
it's like for family to uh turn their
back on you
and not care
no matter what kind of situation you're
in I mean I was 13 when I figured that
out due to my family members kicking me
out of my grandparents house
and uh right after my dad had just
finished buying all my school supplies
so that was fun for like six months of
my life after that just to find a stable
housing
um
then me and my best friend
just recently about a year ago left
Washington because we got tired of
watching our friends drop and die from
all the hard drugs because there was
horse tranquilizer being added to it it
got to the point where you couldn't even
go up and Trust to buy weed from
somebody because there was people
dropping from horse tranquilizer in the
weed
because they were adding it as a
boosting substance as what they would
like to say
to try and increase the high
so far during our travels we haven't
been able to find one place to stay for
more than 24 hours
just like how we were pretty much living
in Washington I've been homeless for two
years
I haven't been able to get my
unemployment and I've been working since
I was 16. back to your childhood like
any abuse anything crazy going on
um
my dad was okay my grandfather is World
War one and World War II vet
so uh even with 15 of his heart and I
weighed about 230 pounds at the time he
could pick me up and throw me across the
room and he did it by my throat
and with one arm
was not a fun experience get thrown
across an entire house
I mean I was being a [__] and when I
get stressed I usually eat a whole lot
I try and keep my Hunger under control
but it gets hard
because all I want to do is eat
everything whether it's
edible or not
uh I have the anxiety
part of it's from the anxiety part of
it's from abandonment issues because at
that same time when my grandparents had
my aunts and uncles kick us out of their
house my mom disappeared for eight
months and my dad went through a whole
mental breakdown so I was the only one
keeping us together the entire time
for two years
I had to do that mentally wake up until
we're making it to my dad and to myself
because my mother wasn't in the picture
though I can't really say my mother's
always been there in the picture she has
a back rat syndrome and not then
great kind she has the severe kind where
she buries things and her mentality
from the age of 10 till they divorced
when I was 22. I watched it go straight
down the [__]
and I do mean straight down the [__]
we took out 35 tons of trash out of the
ground
and then have to put in 350 yards of
dirt just to replace it
because it was filled with nothing and I
mean nothing but trash everything from
something that might be decomposable to
plastic to garbage bags acting as
protection layers to branches to
literal electrical equipment to power
supplies to power cords to just random
junk that was just being buried
some of it she held outside of the
ground she classified as art supplies
even though they were nothing but trash
I mean to the common person it was
pretty much trash and
my dad couldn't handle having that
around anymore because
it was literally dropping the house
property is that like a form of hoarding
yes it uh pack rat syndrome is the
severe version of hoarding
I mean you know of Hoarders who can fill
up their entire houses pack rat means
they will bury it just to keep it
whether it's in the walls whether it's
in the floor whether it's in the ground
or under the house or in the Attic
and that wasn't the only house we had to
clean out my mom actually had her own
house that was filled from the top to
the floor there was only three paths one
to the bathroom one to the kitchen and
one to the backyard
everywhere else
and I'm talking about a one foot space
to be able to walk through
and
we're talking about a space that's kind
of like this
just filled from the floor to the top
just
absolutely nothing but trashed
Electronics
and she just held on to it because her
mind said we'll need it later
and unfortunately my mom's also from a
time period
that
her parents had just gotten out of the
boom age from the Great Depression
because my grandfather was like 95 when
he died my mom's like 62 now no 68. yeah
she would be 68.
and I'm the youngest out of nine seven
it's a little bit young for the
depression
uh yeah
um are you her parents for them probably
the ones that want you there yeah my mom
my mom my dad are the ones who ended up
having to deal with part of that my
dad's like 58 now
um so so back to where you were you were
moving you moved from Washington
to get away from all the people that are
dying from the drugs the hard drugs uh
we just couldn't take it anymore one of
our really close friends that
loved making any kind of candy joke into
a sexual joke literally would sit there
set up candies next to him just so
literally read as a sexist a sec like
sexual joke but it would always be
hilarious
like he would put a Babe Ruth next to a
nut bar
so you netting off the Babe Ruth
it's what do you usually like to say
great
guy at Magic I play it I love card games
um but he was one of those people who
had a really bright future but he killed
over at 18 because of the stuff
he got hooked on to it when he was 16.
literally couldn't live his life without
it this is fentanyl or it was the horse
tranquilizer uh it was fentanyl that he
was buying and unfortunately one of the
places he went to go get it had already
mixed it in
the horse tranquilizer
how they did that I don't know but
that's he literally tried the he from
what I was told from people who had seen
him he had taken three Puffs went to go
across the street to go get something to
drink and died right in the road
literally just collapsed right in the
road
just dead
and that was our 15th friend that it
happened to him
we just couldn't be there without having
all those horrible memories without
being feeling depressed I was literally
smoking two pounds of weed a month
just from depression just to make myself
eat
because I was so stressed I couldn't eat
even though I have a hunger issue so
you're you're a pot smoker
I know everything from
the grow
to the production to the sale
I know all of it all the way down to the
chemical makeup of what you need into
your soil the things you want to add to
your soil if you don't want it to be one
way or you don't want it to come out
another I know how to do it I know how
to make dense nugs I know how to make
fluffy nugs I know how to grow outdoor
and I know how to grow indoor with
controlled light
I know what kind of weather they like I
know it even down to the strain of the
seeds what they would like whether it's
a three-month grow or it might be an
eight month grow I know the whole
process from beginning to end where did
you learn all that uh I learned that at
the age of 16 when I was trying to
decide on what drugs I really wanted to
try
um due to my ADHD I found out there's
probably some drugs I don't want to
touch and I found out in a very bad
experience what one of those can do
that's why I don't touch them anymore
um
I found out instead uh yeah I found out
that the fun drugs make me very angry
and uh not a kind person I guess is the
best way to put it
it's like having a 180 to your whole
personality okay like your grandfather
yeah
kind of how like my grandfather had his
PTSD issues and I had to work with them
as a caretaker helping my mom take care
of them so I had to not only
help them shower I had to help them
get all their things changed whether it
was the catheter or not
trust me I have seen things I never
wanted to see at a young age
and learned a lot of things I didn't
want to know because my brother
fortunately fell into the game and uh I
learned what it does to him
and I just had a really bad time seeing
a lot of stuff happen and when we
started getting harassed every three
hours if we wanted white whether we
wanted shatter whether we wanted Blues
every three hours and we couldn't even
stay in one spot for 24 hours without
the cops showing up and going hey you
gotta move out of city limits
and then we get out of City Limits only
they have the state troopers go hey you
can't be here go back into City
and we did that for literally a year
moving around constantly day in day out
having to find a new spot hoping they
will get left alone for at least
24 hours maybe longer hoping only for it
to not happen
even this trip it's just
been one hassle after another
I mean they did it so they could have a
vacation I did it so I could get some
mental release
from being around all that stress
how much pot are you smoking now
uh
since leaving Washington
I have found out how much Society is
kind of similar I've actually ended up
increasing on my smoking because
normally I don't only smoke two pounds
of weed but uh lately I've been smoking
let's see in the last month
i've smoked
three pounds of flour and about 52 grams
of Wax
which is a lot normally somebody who
only smokes maybe a gram a week
I'm smoking that almost a day
and
I'm mainly just running off of what I
hadn't
in savings and that's about
dry now what's gonna happen when you run
out uh I'm still fighting for my
unemployment if I don't got that at
least have my EBT and just do what I
always do make it work whether I gotta
find some way they exchange stuff for
cash like I did in Oregon I had to
literally uh go out and collect cans
plastic bottles and glass just so I
could afford my smokes and get my pot
even though we had people coming by
where we were at dropping off weed I
started off with about seven pounds a
week
that seven pounds did not last because I
smoked that plus more
which is a lot more than normal people
smoke
and that's just so I can keep my
mentality in the right track because I
have ADHD severely I've had it since I
was three you're not addicted to pot
where are you uh
part of me is probably addicted to it
because it's the only way I can get
sleep now
otherwise
I lay there awake all night
I just feel like all I got the next
morning was just rest like all I did was
get a 20 or 20 hour uh 20 minute nap
that's literally it
and then I pushed myself through the
rest of the day without
trying to snap at somebody without
trying to let any of the stuff just
build up but unfortunately that doesn't
isn't always successful
it's really hard to try and let it
release but at the same time
when it builds up it just builds up
and I smoke a lot of Pop just so I can
keep myself under control
are there any downsides to being such a
habitual pasta smoker uh downsides are
definitely you're constantly hungry you
got hot mouth like [__] all the
time
excuse my language
um like I said irritation from lack of
sleep it definitely gets to you
downsides for the most part is when
you're out
all you want is that next tip
all you're doing is hoping for that next
hit
just to try and make the better look
like it's prettier because otherwise it
just goes great
the whole world just gets a dark tone
it's not as bright it's not as vibrant
the sounds aren't the same
it's like how your brain's running on
normal filter and you're like we're all
the great happy sounds that I was used
to getting so you're you're probably
under the influence of pot 24 hours a
day
easily I don't like going any more than
two hours without pot
I seriously don't go any more than two
hours without pot I have to smoke it
it's not because I don't want to it's
because I have to
see only way I can deal with people I
have anti-social disorder at times so
being in a place where there's over four
million people my anxiety is really up
not as bad as my best friend but
definitely up there
I just try and
make it work with people
it's not always hard easy to do
because having ADHD makes communication
harder
because our brains literally run out a
thousand times the speed of most people
how old are you I just turned 28
yesterday 28. happy birthday
yeah I've been smoking pot now for 11
years
straight
you think you'll stay in this lifestyle
where you're just smoking pot constantly
and living on the streets the rest of
your life uh I got stuck on the streets
because I had a mental breakdown and
then I didn't realize in my contract I
had a way to pause my work for a while
but during my whole mental breakdown I
was trying to get a therapist and
fortunately that just ruined my job so
I lost that and then I've been trying to
get unemployment for literally the last
two years
I mean I don't like not having work
I'm a workaholic
and for the last two years I've had
anxiety from not being able to work
I mean I'd literally walk out spend six
hours a day just to go look for even
simple work from going to door to door
going hey can I do this for you hey can
I do this for you
just for a little bit of money
just so I can get through the day or get
something to eat
because one CBT runs out that's it
and I only got 160 bucks to try and live
off of
a whole month
and unfortunately in Washington that
would about be about 10 days worth of
food
out here I'm looking if I'm lucky
maybe six
just what the prices are
so you need a new Hustle yeah it's I
have to hustle it's the only way I can
stay alive otherwise I'm starving myself
to death
and or end up like what I did yesterday
trying to look for places where I can
get free food and end up showing up late
so I literally went all night last night
without food
I haven't eaten in probably 20 hours
I'm gonna pay you for doing this
probably get some money for coming in
here I was like
I need food sounds good to me nice nice
That's a hot meal unless you see my
money going towards food for a change I
mean that's hot meal to me
that's life
and I'm a foodie so to me food is
pleasure
so being constantly hungry constantly
thirsty
constantly addicted to something that I
want to taste because I actually enjoy
the taste of weed
that's why I like smoking it it's got a
great flavor every type of weed has a
different flavor whether it's Sour
Diesel
Gorilla Glue whether it's one through
five whether it's purple nurple white
kush Snow White whether it's oh even
Marlin's I would love any of that just
for a different flavor
[Music]
because
I'm a weird connoisseur I'm addicted to
stuff but it's probably not gonna stop
this is the best pot you've ever smoked
uh the pot the best one I've probably
ever smoked was uh
it's brand made from Snoop Dogg
um
I think it was snoop snoop
I think it was called that I also have
another one that I like which is space
cookies
just because it actually tastes like a
sugar cookie when you smoke it which is
the weirdest thing to taste when you're
smoking but at the same time it Go makes
you go um
now I want a peanut butter cookie with
jelly in between
and the food ideas you can get on weed
are fantastic because you can make even
the cheapest of cheap meals into
something that's decent taste I mean I
used to take macaroni uh the
uh instantly
noodles and literally an instant pack of
mashed potatoes and a can of chicken
that's a decent meal I don't know its
own
because at least it's gonna stick to
your gut it's at least gonna make you
feel full for a little while
even though it's not really what it's
doing
it's at least masking whatever you feel
which is what a lot of people do when
they're smoking
whatever uh medication they're on it's
what I'm used to saying because you
should get a job growing or as a broker
or something oh I did I worked as a bud
tender for two years
I also worked as a handyman for eight I
was a masseuse for six
and yeah my life has been up and down I
originally was
spent most of my life being a cyber
security to uh video game programmer
because at the time I saw a massive
industry in it and fortunately I started
listening to all my teachers and my
parents saying hey it's not going to be
a real money maker it's not going to be
a real money maker well guess what you
guys were wrong it's a real freaking
Money Maker Now
it's not just cyber security
and I just
Life's a struggle
no matter where you go I mean the hell
I'm from Washington I thought I would be
at least a little bit more decent but
yeah I live all over again what would
you have done differently
if I could have done this all over again
what would I have done differently
um
figured out all my mental problems
probably sooner uh because I didn't know
I have RSD which is rejection
sensitivity disorder
so
it makes that when I like somebody I
can't stand any kind of rejection or
contradiction from them
and I actually have to like the person
for it to affect me otherwise if it's a
normal person yelling at me I'd be like
I don't care
but if it's from that person I just care
a whole lot and I have physically cried
over it just from the whole mental
disease I've literally had to pull over
my car because I could not physically
see even though I did not feel like it
was that bad but because my RSD felt
that that was that such level of
rejection
all I could do was have water tears
going down
I physically could not drive I had the
turnover part just to be able to
spend half an hour just crying until
it's over
and sometimes it just triggers without
reason without warning
there's no signs to it when it goes off
it just happens
it's like having emotional breakdown
without having any control
and RSD really sucks because
I have lost over 40 relationships I'm bi
I've dated both male and women and my
rrc has literally burnt them all to the
ground
I literally feel like I have to be alone
in order to be happy
that'll make you smoke pot
yeah that's rationally why I started
smoking pot is because I was so
depressed I couldn't stand being around
people
because all I saw was a relationship
that I couldn't have
because my RSD literally makes it
impossible
I have physically tried the longest time
I've ever had somebody in a relationship
was literally six months
normally they only last two weeks
and it sucks because
I actually tried to be with those people
but my RSD set kept getting to the point
where I physically start to hear voices
and it will mimic that person's voice
if I'm in the same room I'll start
hearing stuff that's not even coming out
of their mouth but it's my RSD trying to
tell me what it wants
me to think how I should react
and unfortunately I didn't even figure
out that I had RSD until I was 26.
and that was after looking at my own
medical paperwork finally because I was
just like I've been having this stuff
all the time I've never bothered to
actually read it
because I just hand it to one doctor
after another because my mind doesn't
think about it
I don't want to know what I all my
problems are
but after reading it I found out that a
lot of my life issues could have gone
majorly different
like I probably could have gotten into
the uh video game Design Academy that's
in Seattle
with my two hundred thousand dollar
Grant
if I hadn't let my RSD decide that
I wasn't worth going there
Christopher what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
the most important lesson I've learned
in life
is keep a smile on your face push
forward
and
always pass on to another person what
you've at least received so that way it
can be passed on to the next
so that way you're not just the only one
you're always helping the next person
you're always moving forward
there is no looking back because looking
back just
there's no point
it's in the past
all you can do is push forward because
tomorrow's a new day
just because today is the way it is
doesn't mean tomorrow will be
and that's the correct mindset you have
to have otherwise you're just gonna fall
into a spin down cycle and never crawl
yourself out or you'll end up like I did
six years ago so far in a deep rabbit
hole that you don't want to see light
and it just gets bad from there
[Music]
all right Christopher thank you so much
for sharing your story
wish you lots of luck here in Skid Row
try to get out of here as fast as you
can uh that's what we're hoping to get
out of here tomorrow hopefully we don't
run into another complication like we
did last time where our train gets
delayed